technology to make sure we do never we  never forget the past it's an innovative  project over at usc the showa foundation  using artificial intelligence to  preserve stories of the holocaust they  used a giant dome structure you see here  to conduct an interview with 90-year-old  pinchas guter in all they asked him more  than 2 000 questions about his life and  experiencing experience hoping to  future proof his story  a whole week from nine to five a week we  were there with breaks for lunch and but  i was there from nine to five answering  questions oh my gosh  gooder can now be seen at holocaust  museums in dallas in indiana and the  illinois holocaust museum outside of  chicago visitors can ask him their own  questions just like an interactive  interview